[traditional Japanese music]
- Hmm.
[camera shutter clicking]
- Going to send this one
to ninjabuddy08.
Slide up in that bitch DMs
like haha.
You know you like it.
And look at the size of--
[clatter]
[clears throat]
Has the target
been spotted?
- Yes, sir,
the mob boss Franky Fingerstink
and his entourage meeting in
The Tea Bagger fine china shop.
- Clearly a front
for their true hideout.
- This is to be done
in the true ninja way--
quickly, discreetly,
and, above all else, silently.
Send the "dispatchment" team
in now.
- Uh, sir, there is already
an assassin on the scene.
- Yeah, we, uh, told him
we had it,
but he kind of insisted.
- Yeah, uh, in a rather
loud manner.
- Oh, Lord, no.
- All right, all right.
This meeting will come to order.
First order of business--
anybody caught posting selfies
on the organized life
in crime style Web page
will be immediately shot
in the face.
[click, people grumbling]
- Wha--what the hell?
What the hell just happened?
- I bet you spaghetti-slurping
mother[bleep] wondering
what the hell
just happened, huh?
- Well, yeah,
which would explain
why I just asked,
"What the hell just happened?"
- You're asking yourselves
"Where did the lights go?"
"Why am I suddenly
shrouded in darkness
being tormented
by the angel of death?"
Why?
- Oh, shit.
Hey, while that guy was yelling,
I found the light switch.
[people murmuring]
- Right, now, where was I?
Oh, yeah--
tormented by the angel of death,
waiting in darkness
to be slain by the greatest--
God damn it.
- Hey, I got the sandwiches.
You guys sitting around
in the dark for?
- Holy--
- Your time in near!
All you bitches will taste
my cold mother[bleep] steel!
- Why's he yelling?
I thought ninjas were
supposed to be, like, quiet
and stealthy and shit.
- Yeah, I was just thinking
the same thing.
And why is he wearing
fluorescent colors?
You can see this guy coming
a mile away.
- Yeah, not very stealthy
at all.
Pretty shitty
as far as ninjas go.
- Yeah, pretty shitty,
By the way, I am impressed
with your usage of the word
"stealthy."
- Yeah, I've been doing
a bit of reading lately,
you know, in between beating
guys to death with baseball bats
and shooting people
in the head and whatnot,
you know, trying to be
a better me, you know?
- Yeah, I definitely see
a difference.
- Well, thanks for noticing.
- Don't mention--
- My sword is making
you all his bitch!
I'm in your ass
with no kiss!
- Is he rhyming?
Is this guy rhyming
while talking?
God, that's annoying.
This is easily the most annoying
ninja I have ever dealt with.
Well, I mean,
it's the only ninja I--
- Death is my business, bitch,
and business--
Oh, shit, my foot.
- Is this guy serious?
He's the ninja?
The [bleep] ninja tripping
over things in the dark?
- And business is good!
- Yeah, and I'm pretty sure
that's a catch phrase
from some movie or some shit.
- What you gonna do when
I lay my vengeance down on you?
- He just mixed Hulk Hogan
with Samuel Jackson
from "Pulp Fiction."
I can't take no more of this.
- You shoot me, I shoot you?
- Deal.
Sweet relief.